this girl's putting a chest and chest in
the nut blood jeez
getting business what i'm talking about
chest in manchester three
one
dms dating apps i don't have time for
that
i don't believe you should kiss a lot of
frogs to find your prince i believe
in grilling them i'm gonna be going on a
series of dates to find who
can really wow me this is grilling
i'm genetically jacked athletically
stacked half man off amazing modern day
max six foot of chocolate make you
wonder like stevie fam
my name is expressions oozing you know
like that and the girl that's on this
date better not be about this fam i'm
telling you right now i've had my heart
broken fam you know then wait
i'm here to find a proper woman i'm not
trying to see no gala goes to the same
barbers as me
that would be boring my trainers no size
nine foot gal or nothing like that
if she comes to some boy better no
tracksuit on a bmx but i'm going to be
fuming in it i ain't worried about her
she better be worried about me fam i'm
chocolate superman blood you know like
that fam i'm in the nation of domination
i'll be dominating that convo
take a grilling bro i'll take that like
robbie williams and gary barlow fan you
know like that
let's go
oh my days blood this is what i'm
talking about brother i'm tired of these
man setting me up
i'm sorry about that you know what i'm
right there how are you how do
i'm not losing my words geez how are you
doing
your hands are nice and warm yeah it's
soft as well didn't it that headband
no just the outfit i was feeling it but
the headband it killed it killed it how
are you
i'm good what's your name cheyenne oh i
love that name okay what's your name
my name's chocolate superman superman
yeah what makes you chocolate superman
all it is you know i mean i'm half man
half amazing and i'm telling you i
walked over here and you remind me of
christina
milian from the dip it low video rolling
in chocolate boy
i'm telling you i can't believe it my
luck is in
listen blood i'm telling you she's going
to the shops i'm buying a packet of hula
hoop swam she could be putting every
ring on my finger
i'm i'm gonna have more rings than
thanos blood hella stones blood telling
you john stones out here
she's all look she's on man i know that
for a fact blood and if she's not
i swear i'm gonna be single for the rest
of my life cause you can't be looking at
a guy like that undressing me with your
eyes
from the moment i sat down and then told
me you're not feeling me blood lester
that
oh what would you like you like guys
that make you laugh yeah i'm looking for
a man
i am a man i'm half man half amazing
what don't you want a man that's amazing
would you say you're an alpha male you
know what a lot of guys like to say oh
i'm an alpha male i'm the star and the
other
what guy has ever told you that half man
half amazing you know i mean i could do
all the things that a man can do
i can do all the things your man won't
do like joe you know them we're there
do you earn good money but earn good
money yeah yeah i earned pretty decent
money i'm not even i'm wearing a gucci
headband sweetheart let's do some money
oh you want to know how much i earn once
i do my accounts i'll get back to you
it's a bit forward but you're bath still
so i allow you
bro this girl's high sam i couldn't
believe it immediately i'm thinking what
went through my head i'm
that kanye west tune gold diggers came
through my head but i was going to sing
it at the table you know
big man tig she's lucky she was barf
black trust me
if she was a seven she would have
definitely got i would have told her
blood but i can't lie she was she's sexy
fan
so yeah i told her what she wanted to
hear so i'm a bit sick of guys wasting
my time
i want to ask you some intense questions
that usually you don't ask on a first
date
are you okay with that well the way i
see it is rolex don't make belts in it
so there's no point wasting time you
know like that
confident yeah damn right
do you think you're a good catch well i
think i'm exceptional
the only person that can take my girl
away from me is ghost from power you
know like that any other man i'll have
something to say about you
what makes you exceptional to be fair
yeah when you when i go home and i look
at my birth certificate yeah and it says
chocolate superman it just shows me in
it you know i mean i was always made
to be something great and you know i
mean chocolate melts in the sun you see
me i tan
i turn into dark chocolate you like
chocolate i do
yeah we like doing with it
they get a bit you know hot but it was
cool they made me laugh
i feel like i'm a good person are you a
good person yeah let me ask my friends
yeah but your friends are always going
to back you until you're a good person i
heard a charity event in mexico
do you want working with kids you know
in mexico like a lot of kids get
kidnapped i'm not sure if you've seen
the film man on fire by denzel
washington but a lot of kids get
kidnapped in that
and it's really that's not a good thing
in it so i went over there and i mean my
good friend's got a yacht you may know
him like he's very well known his name
is pedro morales no gonzalez
you're steaming up my glasses you know
what color is that top viva la raza
you're making me want to do the
the eddie guerrero and you get me jeez
give me a frog splash any day of the
week this is serious blood you know then
we're there like she's buff blood i
don't want you to just be a tingle i
don't see her again blood
do you want kids definitely how many i'd
say
two minimum you know what i mean but i
would go for more in it do you know what
i mean do you want to
you want to try making something no i
don't want to try making them right now
not yet no would you [ __ ] on first date
i thought you won the first date you're
done right but i don't think that's good
though
what did you mean i'm so fresh and so
clean like andre 3000 but you know them
wait there
but i feel like i can go into my phone
book and show you a text message from
the nhs that says
gonorrhea chlamydia negative but i feel
like it out so easily it just shows you
don't have that much stuff
well look at a question that you've been
asking me but where's your self-respect
about how much money do i earn let's say
here comes the money are you saying that
man sister yeah but i've got it's got
i've got to be right you know i've gotta
know you're earning good money a man
that can support me
support am i universal credit blood
i would like a nice family man family
man you know yeah
elephants i'm after eight nicholas cajun
would you say you're a family man
of course yeah brother it's a family
affair you know i mean like mary j blige
and that trust me i love i love family
yeah yeah what do you call that on your
head headband i was going to wear a hat
because i'd match my um trainers and
that but the thing is yeah like i wanted
to show you i'm taking you seriously in
it
like more time because i do youtube and
that and people always see me with a
house i said you know what
i've got more waves than a caribbean fan
so let me show her that
put on a little gucci headband you know
then wait there and show her that you're
not a man's making that effort
if you like my outfit that's all right
i'm not painting the headband though
you don't like the headband trying to
take it off i don't know what it is i
don't like it take it off
if you take a sign off with me why not
i'm not taking anything off
i find like whenever people wear things
with labels it shows that they don't
actually have money you know like when
you're trying to stunt
yeah are you trying to stunt no of
course not you know what i'm like
i'm very sure i've got internet banking
i know i got money i hate it when people
wear labels it's like oh
i find people that wear labels don't
have that much money
because it's just you're stunning for
what who you trying to impress i don't
like that
how do you think the chat's going yeah i
think it's all right but i mean i'm
definitely
a catch boy nothing to do with kogi you
know like that boy you can definitely
catch me but i'm telling you
i want to see how compatible we are
listen we got more chemistry than a
periodic table baby
yeah yeah look how hard my hands are
over there your hands are there my hands
are here yeah i know but that's because
you're leaning back like fat joe warming
up
no no no no no fat yeah you are fat
p-h-a-t
pretty hot and tempting jeez
no now you know why yeah no no let me
tell you why
because yeah you need something needs to
attract me for me to chat to someone
don't get me wrong if
someone's like my brethren like say i'm
forced into a situation and i'm chatting
to a girl
then i really she's actually a nice girl
but for me say i don't know a girl and
i'm in
like and i'm just walking or i'm in a
club or whatever i'm not going to see a
dead i
mean if a girl look nice to me and she
don't attract me i'm not going to walk
over to her to find out what a
personality is like
do you understand so there's got to be
something that attracts me
you know what i mean it could be my
banner yeah but what am i going to hear
that what am i just going to be hearing
a girl
well again i'm making some jim carrey
jokes like loud in a club in that lesson
i think it's a bit shallow
shallow no i can't swim blood so i don't
it makes no difference to me
would i care would i let her know that i
care you care what i personally care
yeah
yeah you're done right blood why would
you mean
why why would you care what if i stick
with like 100 men
well then i won't be number 101 you know
them way there i am not i'm not a side
man i'm not a lumi cheese that i'm not
calling on a cob fam
i'm steak you know like that if you
slept with 100 and whatever thing yeah
like it's one come on boy i might as
well i might as well go marry a bucket
you know them way there that's what it
is but i might as well just go and rub
one out in the alleyway because that's
how it's gonna feel in the bedroom
how many people have you slept with huh
i'm not gonna lie here double standing
she's asking me all these questions i'll
ask her all them questions if i don't
like what i got here
unless i taken her out i give her a gun
bam you know what i mean bro we can go
to club duvet blood you know them wait
they're fam i'll tell you i already said
she can suck it like triple h and sean
michaels fam degeneration x blood club
do they
might not need to leave my bedroom blood
i don't know if i can count that high
babes
i'm not gonna i don't know how many
girls i slept with so that's a lot yeah
yeah and you wouldn't let me sleep with
the same amount of guys no because i'm
here right now you don't need to sleep
with no one else
date was going well he's making me laugh
but it's this double standard that i
hate in men i think it's just
i think it's quite toxic if i'm honest
now you could have never slept with 100
men look at you boy
no way you'll let 100 men get older that
way no way they don't deserve it
huh but it happens no no no no no no no
it's actually liberated now no we're not
we're not lesser than that
sister but the difference is women lay
on their back open their legs it's more
emotional for you whereas me i could
just turn the girl over and just give
her the
card drogo and khaleesian game of
thrones and that he doesn't have to be
emotional let's be sexist no no it's not
have you got a dick can you do that can
you turn me around and no you can't
yeah we can put in effort you receive
you don't give you're received
you're receiving you receive yeah if
you're playing tennis yeah i'm serving
blood yeah you know
you're a receiver you're hitting it back
why is it okay for a guy to sleep with
100 women but women can't do the same
and
for me this is an issue that i take
quite personally and it's not because
you know i'm sleeping with every man but
i just feel like there shouldn't be this
double standard if you can do it so
should i be able to
talking to tennis you look kind of like
that soccer girl i'm not even gonna lie
but you know you look better though
she might have wimbledon but you got me
in
what if i was a sex worker what's your
thoughts on that you could be anything
you want to be you just won't be with me
blood
no didn't wait there right why do i want
to be with a porn star like let's be
serious
about only fans then yeah that's fine
because only fans doesn't
everyone thinks only fans is all a girl
robin
doing that i know that people can just
create only fans just to have it just
have content that you want private that
people have to pay for
you understand would you subscribe to
miami fans
jeez sorry i i was just like looking at
tia and tamira vlad you know them way
there
sister sister in that boy i swear that
top is low fam you know i mean
looking like a low rider in mexico i
know it's difficult when you've got
someone stood there in like a low-cut
top
but a lot of the time i do actually to
test guys i
want to see if they're looking at me and
they're concentrating to what i'm saying
or if they're looking at my chest
so it's the test do you always look at
women's liars
huh do you always look at women's boobs
on dates i i look at women's boobs that
ask me how much money i'm earning cross
that line i'll cross it as well
i mean this girl's putting a chest and
chest in the nut blood jeez
getting business i'm talking about chest
in manchester
100 i'll definitely want kids one thing
i can say is like
i feel like in this life you can do this
you can make as many moves as you want
you understand but it's about leaving
your legacy it's about building stuff
and leaving it for someone else you
understand
you'll be very selfish of me to not want
children but i've always wanted children
you know i mean what about you yeah it's
cute well dream of me i would like
three kids living on a nice island
with a nice husband looks after me
yes yes would you yeah that's good no
trust issues or anything
i didn't say that did you have trust
issues no i played now i got no trust
issues
i got two phones like kevin gates but
she don't need to know about it i got
two
phones one for the plug and one for the
blue you know them right there
have you ever cheated have i ever
cheated yeah yeah i cheated on one test
in school blood one time i can't lie the
teacher caught me but we move in it
why are you avoiding the question i'm
not avoiding anything sweetheart make it
more specific have you ever cheated in a
relationship
let me get a drink see i know you're
kind you like to
mock the questions to avoid it i know
exactly what you're doing
what is this wine off this is heavenly
what year is this darling
hold on it's just a palette
so yes that's a yes to cheese have i
cheated hell no really come on listen
the way i see it is yeah
what consists is cheating
no i haven't i haven't no big man think
i haven't good i haven't cheated and you
know why
i can tell you i haven't because you see
with me i'm not someone
like i'm i live by the cold don't start
something you ain't got the heart to
finish in it
you know then we're dead there's never
been a thing where i've wanted to bust
my knot so so hard i want to dump
together
that's what kind of foolishness you know
them right there but when the world runs
dry like great david but you know what i
mean and you just got a little noise
over
you you've got to do it have you ever
let anyone on before no
i'm out of pride piper hamlin i don't
need people blood you know then wait
there's good you'd be straight talking
yeah straight talking if you won if you
want to go like the full mile we can do
that if you want to be
fwb we can do that but it's not going to
be friends with ben if it's going to be
friends with big benefits you know
whatever way there because i told you my
drawing with a 9-inch thing
no pizza so you've got a big dick damn
right rav
do you know how to use it yes are you
sure listen i'll take you to fort park
right now boy trust me you'll be water
works in here i don't like reds
what do you her mean
what do you mean yes or no brav yep me
ain't coming in my buddy
why come here what if it's yours then
i'm all for it some girls like sticking
things up there and i'm like i'm not
enjoying it i'm not on that i'm not
doing a hard time like boris kojo family
i've got a clean license i ain't got no
criminal record so why would i want my
body violated like that no you're
sticking nothing up there like less than
that
would you put your dick somewhere what
in a bag yeah would you
you know what yeah shout out pride
festival i'm a big fan of them
rainbow laces skittles all of that but
i'm not sticking my
my uh my johnson's johnson in in no
yeah no no peter bread only in it no no
no batteries and that you get me
oh what you mean with girl oh yeah yeah
no 100 percent family i'll put i stick
that in the stick that euros 100
not not guido yeah
yeah so for me yeah
i'll get married so my wife can have the
same surname as my kids in it
like if it's a big moment for the wife i
think i think
she likes the wedding today like for me
it's not really that big for me don't
get me wrong i fully support it i'll be
there
i'll be happy all of that but i'm doing
it for her and it's not really something
i want to achieve in life
if she gives me a child of course you
can have your wedding because i want
children
no i wouldn't she don't think about it
you're just married for the sake of
keeping her happy yeah
if she wants a wedding she can have that
i don't mind you get me but i'm not
exactly going to be the one
you get me that's oh yeah let's get
married i don't need a piece of paper to
validate my relationship am i a prick
family
sorry for something so you won't get
down on one knee on my knee
i propose i'll get down on one knee with
my mary's right now but you know them
i signed up papers like usher raymond
fan
would i send friends with my ex yes
yeah really yeah
no no no no it's not no it's not no it's
not man said would you be friends with
your ex yeah i could be friends with my
ex don't mean i'm seeing there really i
can be friends with my ex huh
i could be friends with my ex yeah but
you ain't seeing him so you're not
seeing your ex
that's fine i don't i don't want to see
her she's my ex for a reason you know
they might get a triple x like vin
diesel fam
get them out of here
[Music]
i don't even need these glasses i wear
them literally for driving yeah man them
no all my using army and that no i
literally wore these because i want to
make sure yeah
that you get i'm not going to go home be
like oh you know what x you were seven
out of ten bro i want to make sure that
9
or that 10 is a 10 blood jeez
what's like the craziest thing you've
ever done
in a relationship she might get onto
money if i release this information but
we move blood me and i did the bare butt
boogie in a club in it
what the bear butt boogie what's that
you don't know what the bad bug boogie
is
it makes kids darling boogie
damn right boy we we made love in this
club
trust me it's usher's fault in this
place
you made love in this club and i said
you know what i'm swinging several loads
like
i said i'll swing and imagine oh big
mountain
how do you think you're doing on the day
well shouldn't i be asking you how am i
doing on the date you know then well you
haven't walked away
i thought you're going to be doing that
craig david working away
i'm sorry you're still here i love it
yeah you're doing all right what would
you do
if your boys were liking all of my
pictures
they wouldn't my boys wouldn't do that
because my boys look at the ground when
they see my girl my boys don't even know
what my girl look like
they know what training she's wearing
because my boys have respect for me
and any other man they wouldn't what if
they wouldn't be the last thing they see
matt murdock daredevil
you know what i mean they wouldn't
you'll be surprised i've seen
men i wouldn't be surprised because like
my circle's small for a reason
it's the only thing that's smooth though
you know then way there
what would you do if your team is
playing in the champions league
final yeah and i'm in labor well that's
easy
you know then when i go to the football
labor i don't deal with politics
or conservative labor and all that as in
baby oh
baby yeah think about it
my baby yeah yeah we're having a baby
i'm in labor
what's your score i don't know be with
you black
you choose labour yeah labor
jeremy corbyn and that hell no fam i
weren't honest playing she mad bro my
teammate won a trophy since i was born
manga or worthington cupboard i can give
her another kid blood i can't win
another trophy
because it ain't me playing was i honest
less than that bro know them don't tell
her though
what would you do if i told you i wanted
to involve other people in our sex life
better be women i'm all for it brav
trust me we can have a triple threat we
can have a fatal four-way as long as the
gal's nice
you know then we're there and obviously
downstairs ain't smelling like fish
because i don't eat fish
what if it's a guy are you high about it
no that couldn't happen yeah now lester
that leicester i don't know why she was
on this sausage-fest thing bravo i'm
telling you i got enough
i've got enough wood to go around blood
they call me woody allen and that you
get me fam
trust me she don't need to worry about
anyone else's pipes blood you get me
i've got more pipes than british gas
fans so
yeah bro i'm here blood she's nice why
what is it with this double standard
it's not double standards no it's not
no it's not i don't like savilloids yeah
that's what it is i don't like sausage
and batters huh no they won't
you know whatever you can watch porn
yeah it's okay for another woman to
yeah it is because you don't want to ask
me the question so i'm clearly
i'm clearly assuming you like swinging
you know then when you're jerry swingers
and that lester sebastian chris nicholas
and all their man family i like nicola
you know i mean i like tony with an eye
blur not tony with a white blood you
know them way there
what would you do if i farted in bed
well i'll probably make you do a [ __ ]
fight anyway when i'm pounding it so
it's
normal
what would you do if we were together
and i didn't like your mum
well to be fair
it would be beneficial for you to like
my mom you know them wait there but if
you don't
then you just have to wait in the car
blog you know then wait there when i'm
seeing my mom my mom's my queen like she
comes first right you'll be sitting in
the car you'll probably build me a
spliff or something like that and then
i'll come out then we can go back to my
place like nearly no
anthony hamilton and then people there
and then we could just do our thing in
it so you disrespect your mum by being
with someone she didn't like
no my mom doesn't have to no that's
that's foolishness if my mom said if
your mom no my mom got now let's say
that lester that mom
mum when you watch this i hope you're
watching this because i know you love
watching my stuff
mom you can't tell me what gal i can be
with don't get me wrong you can
give me your opinion on her do you know
them wait there if my mom didn't like
her for a reason like say oh she did
something that's different
but if my mom just don't like her is she
high blah my mom ain't laying next to
her
you get me my mom ain't the one having
grandkids with her lesser that blood
yeah i mean my mom would like the
grandkids
you know i know i asked the question
about his mum but for me i'm very big on
like mums
and like family so it was a bit i find
it a bit odd that someone would kind of
like
date someone that mum didn't like
because i personally wouldn't date
someone if my parents didn't like them
that's why i'll get you pregnant quick
if your mama mum didn't like you because
then maybe she'll start to like you when
she sees the kids
what would you do if i asked to see your
dms right now
[Laughter]
i'll decline black decline
why it depends why they are active yeah
they are very active
so you just slide in a lot of women's
dms i don't need to
i'm working in yours my dm's all yeah
they're
yeah they are yeah are you a one woman
man or do you like to play the field and
have
multiple women on the go um tell the
truth
what do you mean so what if i mean if
i'm seeing someone if i'm in a
relationship
yeah if you're saying someone just if
i'm seeing someone that's worth it then
i don't need to see anyone else bro you
know them right there
so how did the date went i think it ran
like usain bolt but you know then we're
there
on the scale of one to ten write
yourself 10 being the highest
rate myself rate me yeah on your game oh
my game 10 team well comment below but
i've got more game than triple h more
game than hunter hurst helmsley fan
you know then we're there more game than
g unit you know like that
what do you think the best part what's
going to happen after the date was i see
the way you'd be looking at me but i'm
telling you but i'm in there
i've got my silk sheets on the bed you
know and i'm like we're going to be
rolling like limb biscuits
the day actually went well i'm not gonna
lie it was funny
made me laugh me personally i think it
went great but
i think it went great she was all over
me fam i'm telling you she's all over me
like a string vest in jamaica
and he's not nice he's felt nice i feel
like that's
that's i'm big on scent so i'm surprised
she didn't ask me what my surname was
because i know she wants that too
i think we're quite comparable we wanted
similar things when it was like the
compatibility round
which was good and he seems like he's a
family man he's got good morals however
i do want to see what's in his dms
though
red flags her asking me how much money i
earned
i thought he was clear blood just look
at me black you know them wait they're
fat
i think everything was perfect
everything was great apart from the
double standard and for me i'm very big
on that
so that's probably the only downside to
the date
don't get me wrong some of the questions
were forwarding that but if she can ask
me that that means i can ask her that
blood you get me i can check her body
count fan
i like his confidence i thought he
smelled nice
well boy you're gonna have to give her
an additional number like because
10 it's too low blood i feel like i'm
going to deduct a point for that
headband because it was actually all
four
10 teen time i told you already not 10
not 11 not 12
not 13 10 teen blood that's what she's
going to give me
actually i would have deducted another
point because you keep more labels for
me like it's
i hate it when people wear labels like
them other man on the day
no disrespect to them because big
yourselves up in that but you mana
hallumi cheese
your coleslaw blood you're corn on the
cob fam i'm
state blood yeah i'm the primary man
here fam you know the way that i move
faster i'm like i'm sin by blood i'm
everywhere
i'm gonna give him a 7.5
[Music]
you